hi this is Barack Obama and I am the
guest editor of the November issue of
Wired we're going to explore what we
call frontiers the theme is those
amazing opportunities and challenges
that are going to be arising as a
consequence of new technology and new
ways of thinking
everything from landing men and women on
Mars to precision medicine and figuring
out how the human genome can unlock some
of the world's deadliest diseases it's
also going to focus on how we work
together to make this happen and that's
going to require leaders not just like
me but also like you
the
so I hope you enjoy the issue look
forward to getting your feedback I think
it looks terrific and the only thing I
notice I think he's misspelled my name
doctor